je viens de terminer mon cm2 je revois
encore ma mère qui le dit regardant mon
but à note pubères ça va pas ah bon
pourquoi maman les t notes en trop bonne
il faut que tu restes à ta place tu
seras massot comme ton père à 10 ans que
vous recevez ça vous refroidit moi je
suis resté en hibernation pendant huit
ans jusqu'à la fin de ma scolarité et
pourtant je rêvais des travaux corps il
faut savoir que sur mon île
mes parents m'ont enseigné des valeurs
très fortes courage et travail mêle
travail laborieux pas le travail
intellectuel
ça c'est pour les feignants en tout cas
c'est ce qui m'a pris mon père lui
partagé fortement ses malheurs
malheureusement il est décédé à 83 ans
sans savoir lire et écrire ceci
d'écouter cela alors après huit années
de scolarité en alternance avec la pêche
à la palourde je suis rentré directement
dans la vie active comme ouvriers à la
chaîne d'une usine de renault
toujours les mêmes gestes faut une
machine d'un même ordre
et là je me suis juré de sortir de ce
carcan social où mes parents m'avaient
entraîner malgré - oui mais comment
comment par le seul moyen à ma
disposition à l'époque la formation
continue mais aussi les valeurs que
m'avait enseigné mes parents courage et
travail alors je rentre tout de suite
dans la vie active comme ouvriers à la
chaîne dans une usine de renault
alors comme j'ai dit aux chefs d'equipe
bien voir qu'il me dit
gilbert c'est bien d'être courageux et
travailleur mais vous n'avez pas votre
bac entre guillemets enrobé dans
quelques années les cours or j'ai décidé
de prendre des cours
et là je savais pas que je vais en
prendre pour 20 ans et une fois j'ai
purgé ma peine
j'ai obtenu un diplôme d'ingénieur au
cnam ingénieurs en organisation et ce
qui est incroyable qu'après 20 ans de
formation continue c'est l'attitude d'un
drh qui me dit d'un ton paternaliste et
condescendant à monsieur corberon jo
c'est très bien d'être courageux et
travailleur mais chez nous un arrêt
bettié et directeur de production
un ingénieur des mines égalant les
usines et à polytechnicien et dix autres
départements
c'est dommage vous n'êtes pas dans la
nomenclature
alors j'ai aussi dit il ya un bug dans
le système managérial
rassurez vous l'avez compris avoir comme
m
mais là je me suis dit faut qu'on fasse
quelque chose puis deux puis c'est mon
métier
non c'est un combat non j'en ai fait un
combat pourquoi il avait fait un combat
parce qu'en 20 ans d'évolution
d'ouvriers à directeur en passant pas
technicien responsable à j 1 des
lecteurs j'ai pris réellement conscience
qu'il y avait des talents cachés à tous
les niveaux hiérarchiques et qui
méritait d'être révélée j'en ai croisé
des personnes bien plus compétentes que
moi qui n'ont pas pu évoluer
pourquoi
selon une légende indienne un jour un
fermier trouve un update par terre il
ramassa et le déposer dans son
poulailler en espérant qu'une boule
biennale couvet et ce fut quand via tran
est un petit aiglons qui sévit aviv avec
une portée de poussins à quatre côtés à
engraisser comme une poule à s'envoler
en perdant quelques plumes ces quelques
mètres à supporter d'humeur du coq et
avoir peur du renard qui rôde
enfin bref il vivait comme une boule
quoi un jour qu'il était en train de
courir avec sa commère la poule il y
passait au dessus lui une ombre un peu
effrayé il regarde on y voit un oiseau
au magnifique majestueux et regarde sa
commère ne rêve pas c'est un aigle tu ne
seras jamais comme lui lui il en rêvait
d un aigle et le sentait dans son corps
qu'il avait la capacité et puis les
semaines les mois les années passèrent
il devient vieux très vieux et finit par
mourir sans savoir qu'il était le roi
des oiseaux puissant fort rapide et avec
une vue perçante alors arrêter de vivre
comme les poules ne vous considérez pas
incapable d'évolution
et si on essayait de d'aborder ensemble
les quatre graines qui permettent de
transformer un aiglon en aigle première
graine le potentiel bien se connaître
permet de se mettre à bonne place alors
vous pouvez demander à votre entourage
pour avoir une perception vos parents
vos enfants votre conjoint esquisseront
objectif sur vos capacités
professionnelles
j'en doute alors c'est quoi vous pouvez
demander à votre entourage professionnel
patron collaborateurs il ya aussi ce qui
seront objectif sur vos capacités
personnelles
j'en doute est ce qui vous dire où tout
sa vérité j'en suis moins sûr
vous faire une terrible confidence j'ai
perdu vingt ans de vie professionnelle
et je m'en suis rendu compte à 50 ans
quand j'ai passé mon bilan de
compétences non blancs potentiels
j'ai bien dit biot potentiel et non
bilan de compétences le bilan de
compétences et un rétroviseur et comme
le dit si bien confucius l'expérience
est une lanterne accroché dans votre dos
qui n'éclaire que le passé alors que le
bilan potentiel est un projecteur qui
éclaire l'avenir le bien de potentiel
s'appuie sur quatre domaines
l'intellectuel le relationnel
l'émotionnel et l'opérationnel
d'ailleurs ce dernier correspond au
bilan de compétences mais ne compte que
pour un quart du bilan de potentiel si
je prends mon exemple par exemple mon
bilan de potentiel révèle des capacités
d'analystes de 1 sur 10 et des capacités
d'innovateur de 10 sur 10 et j'ai fait
toute ma carrière en tant qu'analyste
merdes merci de rire et les ouvriers à
la chaîne électricien responsable
qualité directeur compétitivité
auditeurs enfin bref je vivais comme une
poule
parmi vous quels sont ceux qui sont
pleinement conscientes son potentiel
lever la main
à enghien beaucoup des glands il ya
beaucoup d' aiglons mais ya pas que le
potentiel
il ya aussi la passion la passion se
sont toutes les activités qui nous
animent au quotidien que ce soit
professionnel ou loisirs ce sont des
activités que l'on fait avec plaisir
facilité et on voit pas le temps passer
lorsqu'on compare ses activités et que
son potentiel
on voit tout de suite les points communs
et bingo vous avez les bauges de votre
métier idéal quand j'ai pris des cours
du soir pour passer mon bac
électrotechnique il y avait une matière
qui le passionnait c'était la
productique
donc j'ai approfondi le sujet avec un
bac +2 ou reproductif et là encore il y
avait une matière qui me passionnait la
gestion de production donc j'approfondis
sujet avec un bac + 4 injections de
production et là encore il y avait une
matière qui me passionnait
l'organisation j'ai passé mon diplôme
d'ingénieur en organisation et ainsi de
suite avec le management le coaching et
les talents et je crois que je peux dire
que je suis devenu un expert comme le
dit si bien et george bernard shaw un
espèrer quelqu'un qui sait de plus en
plus de choses dans un domaine de plus
en plus restreint si bien qu'à la fin il
sait tout sur rien
mais là encore plus sérieusement j'en ai
croisé des personnes beaucoup plus
intelligente que moi et qui n'ont pas eu
leur diplôme d'ingénieur qu'est-ce qui a
fait la différence
la passion la passion la patience et un
moteur qui va maintenir votre
détermination et votre motivation pour
aller jusqu'au bout du chemin
mais pour pas s'écarter du chemin il
faut visualiser son étoile comme les
rois mages d'ailleurs malheureusement à
l'école on nous apprend à ses vues son
chemin sur une pancarte unique capacités
intellectuelles en oubliant les autres
pancartes dont j'ai cité à leur
relationnel émotionnel et opérationnel
on trace son chemin
selon une carte préprogrammés bat bac +
2 3 4 5 et lorsqu'on relève la tête on
s'aperçoit trop souvent qu'on s'éloigne
de son étoile et par méconnaissance de
celle ci d'ailleurs d'où la nécessité de
bien connaître son potentiel et
d'ajuster sa formation en permanence des
toiles je vous l'accordé on la voit pas
immédiatement dans son ciel parfois un
distingue à peine simplement quand vous
connaissez bien votre potentiel et votre
passion vous pouvez imaginer votre
projet professionnel
c'est à dire votre étoile comme ce le
fut le cas pour moi
je rêvais d'être avocat et la cabane est
tombée dessus le chien à cause d'un
carcan familial
pour autant mon rêve s'est transformé en
étoile à partir du moment où ma passion
s'aligner avec le potentiel je crois
qu'on peut parler d'aliments des étoiles
oui pour preuve quand j'étais directeur
j'adorerais jouer leur rôle de tuteur et
là j'ai pris conscience que je préférais
être tuteur que directeur est bien passé
de ce moment là j'ai changé de métier et
oui d'abord formateur animateur coach
conférencier et maintenant à vos codes
des talents cachés et je peux dire que
je vis à vis des gains avec beaucoup de
plaisir
c'est vrai que les toits le départ on ne
voit pas très bien pour la définir j'ai
envie de vous donner une méthode axée
vous avec l'avenir accès ça veut dire
planifié ambitieux concrets qui a du
sens et qui était valable
ça évite de dévier sa route parce
qu'avec la ténuité ont peu traître rêvé
de changer d'orientation
surtout bout quelques mois grâce à ça
j'ai pu faire un parcours programmés 20
ans d'évolution de soi celle qui dit
tout à l'heure
d'opérateurs à directeur mes 20 ans
d'évolution des autres de formateurs à
défenseur des talents et sans enfant je
vous assure que je n'aurais pas réussi
alors vint en plus intense et des 40 ans
pas mal ça veut dire que le chemin est
long mais faut pas s'éloigner du chemin
faut pas s'écarter du chemin ils sont
tous pour pas calé pour pas que la
passion notre moteur cale il faut
l'alimenter cette passion avec un
carburant et ce carburant c'est l'auto
apprentissage et j'ai développé ma
propre méthode d'apprendre de tout
apprentissage
grâce à cette méthode
j'ai obtenu le trophée d'information
continue décerné par le ministre ça vous
intéresse que je vous partage la méthode
attention à ces scientifiques d'accord
lecture expérimentation déploiement
audio vous êtes déçu attention c'est une
démarche pragmatique vous allez voir il
pas si concret à petit dans mon train
lecture
tous les cours que j'ai suivi ne
représentait que 20 % de mon
apprentissage les 92% c'était des
lectures sur les matières qui me
passionnait dont j'ai parlé thaler
productique organisation gestion des
terrains et à chaque fois je faisais une
fiche de lecture et des tests de lecture
jeux l'expérimentait ça mon entourage au
départ je me suis dit oh la connaissance
est pas la compétence
je fus très vite rendus compte qu'ils
avaient aucune incidence c'est pourquoi
au royaume des aveugles les borgnes sont
rois
comme c'était le seul à connaître la
méthode je pouvais faire des erreurs
sauf que quand ça marchait je pouvais le
déployer à mon équipe ait eu en retour
il me partageaient leur expérience c'est
à dire qu'il venait alimenter ma spirale
de révélations n'ont que j'ai donné à
cette méthode
parce qu'ici ou non contrairement à la
terre au capital et à l'argent les
connaissances s'accroît quand on les
partage
vous avez compris pour moi l'auto
apprentissage ça a été bon vecteur
d'évolution et si je veux faire
l'analogie avec le sport ça aide à
sportif à devenir un athlète d'auto
apprentissage
c'est comme l'entraînement
l'entraînement mais un sportif ou à
notre lettre il va pas s'entraîner à
n'importe quelle heure moi je révisais
japonais mais matières où je lisais à 10
heures propices et je me relaxe est à
d'autres moments je fais toujours cette
méthode là et comme un athlète et ben je
m'alimente correctement j'ai une hygiène
de vie correcte
c'est à dire que je vais pas essayer
d'avoir toutes les connaissances
possible parce qu'avec les réseaux
sociaux vous pouvez 1
alors si vous voulez vous pouvez très
très vite vous éparpiller eh bien non
oui moi je loge près pareil je vais sur
et sociaux mais mes lectures ils sont
orientés par mon pape et oui
alors je crois que cette méthode apporte
des résultats est sans appel puisque
pour passer des cours d'histoire souvent
notamment quand on aime harvey aucun
diplôme
on est des eaux une centaine de milliers
de personnes à vouloir un diplôme
d'ingénieur
et puis à la fin on est environ un
millier à avoir un diplôme d'ingénieur
et puis mieux encore on est une centaine
avoir une mention dont je fais partie et
ce qui est incroyable c'est que j'étais
juste dans la moyenne
c'est ça que vous donnez comme message
c'est que j'étais même dans la moyenne
basse
c'est incroyable ce qui prouve que tout
le monde je veux y arriver
ce qui prouve que des gens ordinaires
peuvent faire des choses extraordinaires
oui mais à condition à condition de
respecter l'alimentation des cas de
grève potentielle passion
perfectionnement projet
je voudrais partager une conviction
profonde c'est pas une certitude c'est
une conviction vous êtes responsable de
vos talents
ce sont vos richesses professionnels est
ce que vous avez envie de confier vos
richesses personnelles à quelqu'un
d'autre
vos économies l'éducation de vos enfants
l'entretien de votre maison bien sûr que
non alors pourquoi vous confiez vos
richesses professionnels à votre patron
à votre drh à votre hiérarchie
ils sont pas les seuls responsables
en tant qu'avocat des talents nathan je
suis venu plaider une noble cause
aujourd'hui la défense des talents
cachés voir gâcher
je vais vous démontrer que la meilleure
façon la meilleure façon d'évoluer dans
son métier ou de jeu changer de métier
c'est d'inventer son métier j'espère que
j'ai réussi à réveiller
l'aigle qui est en vous parfait
témoignage
oui je vois déjà des yeux perçants qui
brille dans la salle